[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen was im Sport passiert ist das
erfahren Sie von Norbert Lehmann
und wir schauen unter anderem auf den
Raketeneinschlag in Polen
wahrscheinlich ein Querschläger die
raketenexplosion bei deren Polen zwei
Menschen sterben geht wohl auf
ukrainische Flugabwehr zurück
Blamage für Berlin die pannenwahl vom
vergangenen Jahr muss wegen der vielen
Fehler komplett wiederholt werden
und zurück zum Mond nach 50 Jahren will
es die NASA noch mal wissen startet ein
neues Weltraumprogramm und hat dabei
auch gleich den Maß im Blick
[Musik]
nach dem Schrecken über den
Raketeneinschlag und Polen die in
Warnung es bestehe derzeit keine
eindeutige oder Bekannte direkte Gefahr
so der polnische Präsident duda danach
bisherigen Analysen auch durch die NATO
war es eine ukrainische Flugabwehrrakete
die versehentlich polnisches Gebiet
getroffen hat kein russischer Angriff
zwei Menschen wurden getötet über das
was bisher über den Vorfall bekannt ist
luten leinhaus die Rakete schlägt ein in
einem polnischen Bauernhof sie zerstört
dort einen Traktor samt Anhänger tötet
den Fahrer und einen Kollegen warum nur
der Angriff hier
der Einschlagsort liegt unmittelbar an
der ukrainischen Grenze nahe schäferdorf
in Polen die nächste Stadt in der
Ukraine Lemberg ist 70 km entfernt dort
fiel gestern stundenlang der Strom aus
nach einem russischen Angriff mit
Langstreckenraketen anders in Polen die
Trümmer dort sagt die Regierungen
Warschau stammen von einer Rakete kurzer
Reichweite einer S300 die fliegt maximal
200 km weit kann somit nicht in Russland
abgefeuert worden sein sie ist
eigentlich ein russisches
Flugabwehrsystem wird aber auch von der
Ukraine eingesetzt vermutlich ist
gestern genau das passiert wo die
Ukraine versucht haben auf eine eine
russische cruise-missile zu schießen und
dann eben anscheinend entweder nicht
getroffen haben oder eine Fehlfunktion
in der Rakete vorgefallen ist und dann
ist die sozusagen in Polen
runtergekommen aber aus dem Lagebild aus
dem was wir wissen dass das so in etwa
der wahrscheinlichste Ablauf vermutlich
so der Experte hätten die Ukraine die
Rakete eingesetzt um einen russischen
Angriff auf eine Stromtrasse im
Grenzgebiet abzuwehren
Ukraine dagegen macht für den
Raketeneinschlag Russland verantwortlich
der Sekretär des nationalen
Sicherheitsrates der Ukraine sagte dazu
jetzt die Ukraine wolle Einsicht in
Informationen dass es sich um eine
ukraineische abwehrrakete gehandelt habe
wie die NATO-Länder auf den Einschlag
reagieren berichtet ulfrella
als die ersten Bilder vom
Raketeneinschlag auftauchten hielt die
Welt den Atem an doch die Spurensuche
ging schnell denn der Luftraum wird
engmaschig überwacht
Präsident beiden Schienen deshalb gut
von seinen Geheimdiensten informiert zu
sein der Grund für den Zwischenfall sah
eine fehlgeleitete ukrainische
Luftabwehrrakete und nicht eine
russische Rakete ich kann es nicht genau
sagen es muss noch untersucht werden die
Flugbahn der Rakete macht den Abschuss
von Russland unwahrscheinlich aber wir
werden sehen
Krisensitzung der NATO am Morgen nach
zweieinhalb Stunden stellt
Generalsekretär Stoltenberg fest wir
haben no indication wir haben keinen
Hinweis dass dies ein gezielter Angriff
gewesen ist wir haben auch keinen
Hinweis dass Russland einen
Militärschlag gegen die NATO planto
doch das dürfte die Menschen an der
polnisch-ukrainischen Grenze nicht
beruhigen sie hören noch den Knall der
einschlagenden Rakete
dieses Geräusch hatte einen riesigen
Schock verursacht riesige Angst
russland hatte gestern die Ukraine unter
massiven Beschuss genommen deshalb
machte Bundeskanzler Scholz Moskau für
den Zwischenfall an der
polnisch-ukrainischen Grenze im
ZDF-Interview verantwortlich wir wissen
natürlich gleichzeitig dass das alles
egal von wem die Rakete abgeschossen
wurde und welches Ziel sie eigentlich
hatte nicht stattfinden würde wenn es
nicht den furchtbaren Krieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine gebe
die NATO Verbündeten wollen die
ukrainische Luftabwehr weiter stärken
damit sie sich noch besser gegen die
russischen Angriffe wehren kann
gehen wir nach Brüssel zu Florian
neuhahn Florian dieser Vorfall hätte ja
auch wirklich leicht eskalieren können
was kann man aus diesen vergangenen 24
Stunden ziehen
das war gestern vielleicht der Moment
der größten Anspannung im NATO
Hauptquartier seit Monaten weil zum
ersten Mal tatsächlich die Möglichkeit
im Raum stand das Russland einen Angriff
auf nahezugebiet gestartet hatte mit
einem Tag Abstand würde ich daraus drei
grundsätzliche Lehren ziehen erstens war
tatsächlich hat dieser Vorfall noch mal
allen deutlich vor Augen geführt wie
gefährlich nah dieser Krieg an die NATO
heranrücken ist und wie schnell er auch
auf einen natoland überschwappen könnte
und zweitens aber war die Besonderheit
der westlichen Reaktion wohl
entscheidend dass es nicht zu einer
weiteren Eskalation kam mit vielleicht
einer Ausnahme der ukrainische Präsident
selenski der gestern Abend direkt von
einem russischen Angriff auf Polen
sprach aber damit allein auf weiter Flur
stand und drittens hat der christliche
Abend wohl auch gezeigt so höre ich dass
die militärischen Gesprächskanäle
zwischen Russland und Westen weiterhin
intakt sind und das hilft in solchen
Momenten eine unbeabsichtigte Eskalation
zu vermeiden und das ist auch für die
Zukunft wichtig denn dieser Krieg dürfte
ja noch lange dauern und irgendwelche
Vorfälle sind keineswegs ausgeschlossen
Dankeschön für diese Einordnung Florian
Herrn
und auch da G20-Gipfel auf Bali der
heute zu Ende ging stand ganz im Zeichen
des russischen Angriffskrieges auf die
Ukraine brachte aber auch unerwartete
Einigkeit im gemeinsamen kommunik
verurteilen die meisten teilnehmenden
den Krieg scharf so die Formulierung
auch China und Indien stimmten der
Erklärung zu Russlands abweichende
Haltung wurde im Protokoll festgehalten
Mr teven ist Russland dadurch jetzt noch
stärker isoliert
das kann man wohl sagen und zum größten
Teil aus eigener Schuld denn da saßen ja
eine Reihe von Ländern mit am Tisch die
selbst massiv unter den Folgen dieses
Krieges leiden Energiekrise
Nahrungsmittel Knappheit in China lahmt
die Wirtschaft beispielsweise und in all
diesen Punkten und auch in dem Punkt
Klimawandel Kampf gegen den Klimawandel
hat es keine wirklich zählbaren
Ergebnisse keine Ergebnisse sehen der
Abschlusserklärung von diesem Gipfel
gegeben weil eben der Krieg alles
überschattet und im Grunde genommen
unmöglich macht und gleichzeitig ist es
eben auch so gewesen dass während dieses
Gipfels Russland dann zahlreiche Raketen
eine Barrage regelrecht gegen die
Ukraine geschickt hat das hat Länder wie
Argentinien Südafrika und Senegal empört
die haben dann noch mal am Text selber
mit nachgeschärft und selbst China war
nicht mehr bereit am Ende an die Seite
Russlands zu treten und diese scharfen
Text zu verhindern der indische
Premierminister Modi hat beispielsweise
auch dem russischen größter die kalte
Schulter gezeigt also es ist kein Bruch
aber es zeigen sich eben Risse leichter
Absetzbewegungen und Russland muss
wahrscheinlich einiges tun um das wieder
zu kitten
vielen Dank
Russland also in der Defensive
diplomatisch aber auch militärisch wir
blicken nach hashorn nach dem Abzug des
russischen Militärs dort muss die Stadt
wieder bewohnbar und sicher gemacht
werden und es werden Spuren und Aussagen
gesammelt um mögliche Kriegsverbrechen
zu dokumentieren aus trasson berichtet
Henna Hebestreit
es ist eine lebensgefährliche Arbeit
ukrainische minenentschärfer suchen die
Gegend um das befreitete Person nach
versteckten Sprengfallen ab
internationale Medien werden von der
ukrainischen Polizei durch hersong
gefahren die Behörden wollen zeigen wie
zügig sie versuchen die Kontrolle über
die 300.000 Einwohner Stadt zurück zu
gewinnen Minen bleiben auch nach dem
Abzug der Russen eine gefährliche
Hinterlassenschaft
wir haben bereits etwa 189 Gebäude und
200 km Straße und auch eine große Zahl
an Einrichtungen der Energieversorgung
von Minen und Kampfmitteln befreit
mit dem Abzug von Putin Soldaten
beginnen Ermittlungen zu möglichen
Verbrechen während ihrer Besatzungszeit
die Polizei berichtet sie habe Verhören
Folterzentren gefunden im Kellern von
Wohnhäusern aber auch in Schulen und in
dieser Polizeistation Maxim erzählt uns
dass er hier erst physisch unter dem
psychisch misshandelt
haben drohten sie meiner Tochter oder
meiner Mutter etwas anzutun vor ihrem
Abzug haben die Russen große Teile der
Infrastruktur zerstört erste mobile
Hotspots bringen dich Hessen das
Internet zurück auch wenn es jetzt an
einigen Stellen in der Stadt schon
wieder Internetverbindungen gibt es
risson noch weit weg von jeglicher
Normalität es gibt zum Beispiel immer
noch kein Wasser und keinen Strom das
alles ertragen sie geduldig endlich
können sie ihren Verwandten in anderen
Teilen in der Ukraine berichten dass es
ihnen gut geht und was sie in den
letzten Monaten durchgemacht haben
nach Deutschland es ist ein Debakel für
die Hauptstadt die Berlinerinnen und
Berliner müssen eher Abgeordnetenhaus
und ihre Bezirksparlamente neu wählen
denn der Berliner Verfassungsgerichtshof
hat die Wahlen vom vergangenen Jahr für
ungültig erklärt wegen schwerer
Wahlfehler und so sahen sie aus zu wenig
Wahlurnen zu wenig oder falsche
Stimmzettel vor den Wahllokalen lange
Schlangen mit stundenlangen Wartezeiten
teilweise wurde auch noch nach 18 Uhr
gewählt all das könnte sich auf das
Ergebnis ausgewirkt haben mehr von
Stefan Merseburger
das Urteil ist vernichtend schon die
Wahlvorbereitung war so schlecht dass
Sie weitere pannenbedingte Versäumnisse
so das Gericht die einmalig in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik sind die
Häufigkeit und Schwere der Wahlfehler
führt nach Auffassung des
Verfassungsgerichtshofs zu der einzigen
Möglichkeit das nämlich die Wahlen in
ganz Berlin wiederholt werden müssen nur
so können demokratische Standards
aufrechterhalten werden und zumutbare
Wartezeiten zu wenige Kabinen falsche
fehlende oder kopierte Wahlzettel
vielfache Stimmabgaben nach 18 Uhr ein
für Berlin beschämendes wahlchaos da
zumindest herrscht Einigkeit bei
Regierung und Opposition
und ich glaube wenn dieses Urteil eins
deutlich gemacht hat so wie Berlin
regiert wird so wie Berlin strukturiert
ist so darf es nicht bleiben
selbstverständlich müssen wir alles
dafür tun dass so etwas nie wieder
vorkommt bei der nächsten
Wahlwiederholung darf nichts schiefgehen
aber es bedeutet auch wir können jetzt
nicht einfach zu Tagesordnung übergehen
eine grüne Spitze gegen
Koalitionspartner SPD Andreas Geisel
heute Bau und damals in Senator trägt
die politische Verantwortung für die
Organisation der chaoswahl bei der
Franziska Giffey Bürgermeisterin wurde
Schadensbegrenzung
ich bin selbst in
Verantwortung heute war aber nicht in
der Verantwortung als diese Wahl erfolgt
ist wir bringen Berlin gut durch die
Krise wir kümmern uns um die Aufgaben
die jetzt anstehen der Kampf um die
Stimmen hat begonnen Wahlwiederholung
wahrscheinlich am 12 Februar
in den USA sind 2024
Präsidentschaftswahlen und einer der
antreten will steht schon mal fest
Donald Trump der Ex-Präsident will
zurück ins Weiße Haus aber nachdem
zahlreiche von Trump unterstützte
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten bei den
Kongresswahlen verloren haben wenn die
Stimmen in der republikanischen Partei
immer lauter die nicht noch mal auf
Trump setzen wollen über die Reaktionen
auf Toms Wahlkampagnen statt Klaudia
Bates
der Glanz trügt denn der Zeitpunkt hätte
für die Republikaner nicht schlechter
sein können enge Berater hatten ihn
gedrängt die Ankündigung zu verschieben
nach den enttäuschenden Ergebnissen vor
allem der von Trump unterstützten
Kandidaten bei den Zwischenwahlen aber
dennoch
um Amerika wieder großartig und
ruhmreich zu machen kündige ich meine
Kandidatur für die Präsidentschaft an
Trump möchte zwei Jahre vor der Wahl
mögliche innerparteiliche
Gegenkandidaten gleich auf Abstand
halten und hofft wohl vergeblich
geschützt zu sein vor Strafverfolgung
bei seinen vielen rechtlichen
Auseinandersetzungen Präsident beiden
wackelig gefilmt beim G20-Gipfel tauscht
ein Grinsen aus mit dem französischen
Präsidenten möchte er die Ankündigung
Trumps kommentieren
nicht wirklich murmelt er nur
jenseits von Trumps treuesten Fans sind
auch viele Republikaner skeptisch und
meinen nein es sei Zeit nach vorn zu
schauen
er ist ungeeignet seine Rede war nicht
inspirierend und es ist Zeit bei den
Republikanern und den Demokraten für die
nächste Führungsgeneration
gemeint ist ronde Säntis der als
Gouverneur von Florida letzte Woche ein
furioses Wahlergebnis eingefahren hat
die Großspender um schwärmen ihn der
ultrakonservative gilt als die Zukunft
der Partei
die Republikaner fürchten dass sie mit
Trump keine Wahlen mehr gewinnen können
nun können Sie sich entweder dennoch
wieder hinter ihm einreihen oder sie
riskieren schwere innerparteiliche
Kämpfe wenn sie sich von ihm abwenden
die republikanische Partei steht vor
einer echten Zerreißprobe
mehr als 30 Jahren nach einem tödlichen
Brandanschlag auf eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft in Saarlouis hat
der Prozess gegen den mutmaßlichen Täter
begonnen angeklagt ist ein 51-jähriger
Rechtsextremist die Bundesanwaltschaft
wirft dem deutschen unter anderem Mord
und Brandstiftung mit Todesfolge vor der
Mann soll im September 1991 aus
rassistischen Gründen Feuer in der
Flüchtlingsunterkunft gelegt haben der
27-Jährige Samuel jebohrer aus Ghana
starb die anderen Bewohnerinnen und
Bewohner konnten sich retten
keine Anhaltspunkte für ein politisches
Motiv gibt es offenbar nach dem Brand in
einer Unterkunft für geflüchtete in
großströmkendorf weil Wismar vor vier
Wochen laut Staatsanwaltschaft wurde
jetzt ein Feuerwehrmann aus der Region
festgenommen er soll noch weitere Brände
gelegt haben in der Nacht zum 20 Oktober
war das Gebäude in dem geflüchtete aus
der Ukraine wohnten ausgebrannt verletzt
oder niemand
nach monatelanger Verzögerung wegen
technischer Probleme und schlechten
Wetters hieß es nun endlich startfrei
für die artemis-mission der NASA das
Ziel noch vielen Jahrzehnten wieder der
Mond mit an Bord der neuen
schwerlastrakete die noch unbemannte
Raumkapseln Orion sie wurde zusammen mit
der ESA gebaut und wesentliche Teile
kommen aus Deutschland in rund zwei
Jahren soll die Raumkapsel
astronautinnen und Astronauten zum Mond
bringen und später auch zu einer neu
geplanten Raumstation diese soll dann
als Beobachtungsposten und
hightech-labor um den mondkreisen Verena
guide
an Bord keine Astronauten sondern Puppen
ausgestattet mit Sensoren die Vibration
Beschleunigung und Strahlungswerte
aufzeichnen sollen
dieses Mal passte alles um 1:48 Uhr
Ortszeit hob die mächtige Mondrakete SLS
in Florida ab hunderttausende sahen vor
Ort zu darunter einer der bei der
nächsten Mission mit nach oben will
eine Rakete starten zu sehen wenn man
als Astronaut oder als Astronautin weiß
man hat eine Chance da vielleicht selbst
mit zu fliegen und man kommt nicht umhin
zu überlegen ja wie wäre es denn jetzt
die Raumkapsel Orion auf ihrer Reise
soll sie unter anderem
Forschungssatelliten aussetzen die als
Ablagerungen auf dem Mund erkunden große
Teile und das hauptantriebssystem wurden
bei Airbus in Bremen gebaut erstmals bei
einer Mondmission ist Europa mit dabei
10 europäische Staaten beteiligt
der Globuli in Devil es ist ein globales
Unterfangen wir wollen den Mund
erforschen besonders das Südpol Gebiet
Bereiche die wir noch nicht erfasst
haben und wir wollen langfristig einen
dauerhaften Außenposten in der
Umlaufbahn des Mondes errichten
Artemis 1 transportiert keine Menschen
zum Mond aber den Traum Europas von
einer neuen Ära in der Raumfahrt am 11
dezember soll Orient auf die Erde
zurückkehren
[Musik]
und wenn sie sich selbst auf den Weg ins
All machen möchten empfehlen wir unsere
ZDF heute App dort können sie sich nicht
nur zum Mond klicken und Zoomen sondern
interaktiv die neue Raumstation erkunden
und mehr über die Mission Artemis
erfahren
zurück zur Erde zum Sport Norbert da
macht ihr heute aus deutscher Sicht mal
nicht Fußball sondern Eishockey
Schlagzeilen
Überraschung Bundestrainer Toni
Söderholm wirft nach vier Jahren das
Handtuch und wechselt zum Schweizer
Spitzenklub SC Bern der 44-Jährige hatte
erst im Frühjahr seinen Vertrag bis 2026
verlängert in den letzten Jahren hatte
er das deutsche Eishockey Team
erfolgreich gecoacht und die Mannschaft
bei der WM in Finnland bis ins
Viertelfinale geführt ein Nachfolger für
süderholm steht noch nicht fest
keine Medaillenchancen mehr für die
deutschen Handballerinnen bei der EM
aber noch Hoffnung auf Rang 5 nach der
Niederlage gestern Abend ging Frankreich
verpasste das DHB-Team das Halbfinale
siegte aber heute im letzten
hauptbrunnenspiel gegen Rumänien mit 32
zu 28 ein fünfter Platz bei der EM
könnte noch für die
Olympia-Qualifikation von Bedeutung sein
[Applaus]
zur Fußball-WM frankreich muss auf dem
verletzten Leipziger Topstürmer
Christopher Kuku verzichten dafür
rücktrendahl kolumani von Eintracht
Frankfurt ins Team des Weltmeisters
Trainer die die Show hat den 23-Jährigen
heute nachnominiert
der Austragungsort Katar der ist ja
durchaus umstritten aber es gibt Länder
das Spielen kritische Themen überhaupt
gar keine Rolle zum Beispiel Brasilien
eine ganze Nation freut sich auf die WM
und hofft durch Fußball wieder eine
ganze Nation zu werden
Fußball kann Vereinen darauf hoffen Sie
in diesem Jahr in Brasilien nach einem
aufreibenden Präsidentschaftswahlkampf
sehnt sich das Land nach einem Stück
Normalität Anhänger des ultrarechten
Präsidenten bolsonaro hatten das
Nationaltrikot zum wahlkampfsymbol
gemacht grün und gelb sollen jetzt
wieder nur noch für die celezaro stehen
hier ist es egal ob jemand für bolsonaro
Lula oder sonst was ist zieh das Trikot
über und feure Brasilien an und damit
basta
die WM soll das Land wieder
zusammenführen gerade das brauchen Sie
hier den Brasilianern geht es weniger um
die Menschenrechte in Katar als um ein
erfolgreiches Fußballfest mitsamt großem
Public Viewing am Copacabana Strand
das wars
und das sind die Lottozahlen die
Gewinnzahlen lauten 1 9 11 30 35 37
Superzahl ist die 8 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 557
lange war es ja viel zu mild für
November das ändert sich in dieser Woche
wie kalt es wird und ob die Kälte alle
trifft das erklärt Ihnen gleich Katja
horneffer das heute journal können Sie
an diesem Abend um 22 Uhr sehen mit
Christian Sievers auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute zog ein Regenband von
Südwest nach Nordost den äußersten
Nordosten hat es nicht erreicht denn
kräftiger Ostwind hielt dagegen so wurde
dieses Wolkenband auseinandergerissen
und die Temperaturen lagen recht
unterschiedlich nur vier Grad waren es
im östlichen Bayern 15 Grad dagegen am
Oberrhein auch die Nachttemperaturen
sind im Westen recht mild mit
tiefswerten zwischen 9 und 7 Grad im
Nordosten wird es bei drei bis ein Grad
kälter und dabei fällt noch Regen heute
Nacht hier zwischen der Lausitz und
Schleswig-Holstein neuer Regen kommt von
Südwesten heran und der breitet sich im
Laufe des Tages weiter nordostwärts aus
und genau wie heute wird er den
äußersten Nordosten wieder nicht
erreichen das liegt an dem starken des
stürmischen Wind aus Ost südöstlichen
Richtungen im Südwesten lockern die
Wolken dagegen auf und mit Sonnenschein
und Südwestwind klettern dort die
Temperaturen bis 17 Grad deutlich kälter
bleibt es hier an der Ostsee und dann
breitet sich diese Kälte über ganz
Deutschland aus wir erwarten Alltag dann
Höchsttemperaturen von nur noch 0 bis 10
Grad gefährlich wird wenn der milde
Regen über die Kälte am Boden zieht dann
droht Glatteis sonst nur Schneeregen
guten Abend